[Music]
you had a topless scene on the show
which which may have been made you know
a lot of people nervous or feel
self-conscious Network top was there I'm
Network topless right now I still
haven't developed but I thought your
crew did a very nice thing the crew that
works on the show to make you more at
ease they all took their tops off in
solidarity solidarity and you shot the
scene in solidarity and then I had to
get a photo of it and then I had to you
know everybody when you take a photo now
you have all these options for filters
and doing this or that so I put this
filter on it and posted it and
afterwards was like this looks like
really porny it looks like a very
out-there so I have worn filters that
come on the apps now the 70s it's called
the 70s yeah I think we should we're
gonna start airing this show all in the
porno theater
let's take a look at that picture I
think we have it here this is you guys
all hey I don't need to see that glow I
don't want to see my crew topless sorry
fellas
I don't think you want to see me topless
you